okay hi everyone so I'm going to sort of
continue on what Sheila were talked
about in the previous lecture and sort
of introduce some more sort of ideas
into the mathematical models that we use
in population genetics so I'm going to
particularly introduce demography and
structure and also introduce
recombination which will relate the
haplotypes at multiple the low side or
positions in the genome okay so to
quickly and quickly recap what we saw in
the last lecture we have this simple
model this right Fisher model which is a
discrete time model of meeting and as we
take the population size to infinity we
you and we rescale time suitably we get
this continuous time process called the
Collison process so in this this
continuous time process is a Markov
chain which tracks the number of
ancestors of a sample of size and drawn
from the present such that when the
number of ancestors is K the the
transition rate is 2 K minus 1 ancestors
that rate K choose 2 so the waiting time
while there are K ancestors this
distributed according to an exponential
random variable with rate K choose 2 and
on top of this genealogical process so
this process gives you a tree at this
disposition of the genome for the sample
of size n drawn from the present you can
then impose mutations on top of this
tree to get the allelic types of the
sampled individuals at this position of
the genome ok but now you know you can
ask what if so we assume in this right
Fisher model that there was a constant
population size and we developed this
coalescence continuum this continuum
limit but you might ask what happens if
the population size changes over time of
that or if there is more complicated
structure in the population in that the
population is not simply randomly mating
but maybe there there is some draw
graphical dispersion of the population
then what can you sort of how can you
extend these models also you might want
to ask what if you have multiple
positions of the genome that you're
interested in tracking so you're looking
at the genealogical ancestry of multiple
positions and then the types at those
positions and they're a very important
biological process called recombination
actually creates correlations in the
genealogies at different positions
so we'd like to model that also and you
know just to sort of step back a bit and
see what you know what does all this
theory that we are developing by us and
what what do we what would we like to do
with it so sort of at the most basic
level this theory is a generative model
of data sequence data that you you know
when you then get this data you can try
to fit parameters that you're using in
this theory and the hope is that these
parameters model some kind of real sort
of these the parameters of the
underlying biological processes so for
example we model the mutation rate in
the squalus and framework or the
recombination rate in this collison
framework the hope is that these these
parameters that you use in your morals
have some realistic meaning well so we
are interesting capturing the most
important biological dynamics and
mechanisms in these models with those
parameters and you know with demography
you'd like to infer a sort of the
general demographic structure of the
population which has many applications
as I've mentioned in a few slides
and you know under this theory you can
also sort of a model selection and then
you'd like to understand which regions
of the genome are in the selection when
you're examining genetic data taken from
the population so now to get into
democratic structure we want to augment
this coalition process that we talked
about in the in the previous lecture
with demography so as an example this is
a this is sort of a demographic sort of
peopling of the world map estimated from
real genetic data so sort of those
estimate that you know the ancestors of
modern humans that we see the extant
species at the moment originated sort of
in southern Africa and around sixty two
hundred thousand years ago there was
sort of um up work there was a northern
word migration and then there was an out
of africa migration around fifty to
sixty thousand years ago there was a
wave that moved into europe another wave
that moved into Eurasia and sort of
along the southern parts of Asia they
further moved into Australia and sort of
the most recent migrations happened sort
of wire the Bering Strait bridge of
50,000 years ago into sort of North
America and sort of more recently into
South America so so sort of this kind of
you know this kind of map of
human demography and sort of human
ancestry can be estimated from genetic
data and sort of we will use the models
that I'll talk about to actually make
these estimates and in fact that's what
they did to come up with these estimates
so but you know beyond just historical
curiosity what's why would we like to in
sort of model demography what is the
importance of this so as you see in a
few slides the demographic processes
that generate that that underlie the
population actually influence the
distribution of genetic variation that
you see in data so this has obvious
implications for all kinds of things
from sort of conservation genetics where
you maybe like to try to figure out the
you know the population of or the number
of surviving individuals of the species
just by sampling from from the from the
sort of wild and it has applications to
sort of medical genetics also where the
frequency of variants whether they are
rare variants or common variants is sort
of that that affects the propensity for
these diseases and how correlated the
diseases are with with the markers in
the genome further when you're doing
these genetic studies where you're
taking the phenotypic data and you're
looking at whether the individual has
some disease or not and you've tried if
you find markers of sort of relevance
which are correlated with the disease
you actually have to take into account
population structure also because you
might actually find spurious
correlations between the markers that
you've that you've done in you found in
your tests and actually the the disease
just because the frequency of the the
markers or these alleles is different
between different subpopulations so
population structure can actually
confirm your your association studies
your simple correlation based studies
you'd also like to find these to get the
correct null model for distribution of
variation in your genome so that may be
if you're trying to test against
deviation from these null mortars let's
say for example your null model is that
you know this these regions of the
genome are evolving usually there's no
selective pressure acting on them and
you you don't model the demography of
the region properly and then you find
that there's a deviation from
predictions under your model then you
might you might then say that it's
actually due to selection acting and on
those regions but it could very well be
that you didn't model the
MOG Rafi properly so actually a null
model was wrong to begin with and if you
had actually modeled the demography
properly you no longer may have had a
significant signal for selection so
you'd like to get correct null models
for doing various kinds of statistical
tests it's also importance in forensics
where for example people courts look at
the probability that sample at the crime
scene matches some profile from a
database of individuals who were maybe
convicted in the past or were suspects
in investigations and if the probability
of match is low that might be evidence
for maybe further investigation into
this these suspects it turns out that in
these models where you compute these
probabilities it's important to actually
model the demography and take that into
account when calculating these
probabilities okay so to start off with
the the simplest way to introduce
demography is to have you know a single
randomly mating population but now this
population size is no longer constant
it's no longer the equilibrium you have
some changing population size over time
so we'll start with this right Fisher
model but you know things are randomly
mating but at time T there's a
population size function n of T and now
when you know like in the usual right
Fisher process so we're going to label
time the current time would be time zero
and going back in time T would be
increasing this parameter and at
generation T you'll generate NT
offspring where each offspring would
pick its parent uniformly at random
independently and uniformly at random
from the previous generation now you can
sort of take this the the same kind of
continuum limit as we did earlier with
you know population size that ginge
didn't change in time so we will take
sort of all these population sizes at
every time to infinity at the same rate
and we'll choose a rescaling parameter
so that we can get this continuous time
process so you know this curly end would
be this rescaling parameter for time and
if you rescale time by that parameter
and sort of we normalize the populations
by this amount such that this relative
population size this ETA T is some
exists and it's it's it's some constant
for every T then we get this coalescing
process now we're now
that the coalescence rates in this
process are no longer time inhomogeneous
they actually depend on time because
this reflects the fact that the
population size is changing over time so
now when you draw a sample of size n at
time zero you can you can talk about the
coalescence rate and you know the in the
time variable coalescence rate is now 1
over this relative population size each
at E so what this means is that if this
relative population size is small then
the coalescence rates are higher
intuitively this makes sense because if
the co if the population size is small
two individuals in your sample are more
likely to find an ancestor quickly just
because the population size is small so
this that that explains why you have
this 1 over HIV but you can get this
formally by by taking this limit and
doing the same kind of math that she
talked about earlier to get the
coalition process from a constant
population size so as as I described the
the population size changes in a
deterministic fashion over time you can
also incorporate sort of where the
population size changes randomly there
is some variability in the population
size obeys I change deterministic and it
is this this work so when you take this
continuum limit you are getting this
this this ETA T function right so really
you have a sequence of pre limiting
models or discrete time models that when
you take the continuum limit you get
this process and as so I sort of mix
both the taking the limit part of to
sort of give the intuition and also the
the actual construction of this
continuum limit but but informally this
this continuum limit you can you can
take any function each RT doesn't have
to be continuous for example
coalescence is such that you only have
to worry about right so you would have
similar condition says in the previous
talk where he had this smaller Schlemmer
that sort of the established necessity
and sufficiency for convergence to the
king Monaco lesson so all this is for
the king when koala sent but I mean you
can probably extend these lamda
coalescence also these other more
general coalescence also to handle a
varying population size
okay so sort of to give a pictorial
representation of what this variable
population size collation process looks
like so this blue line denotes this this
this population size or it's scaled
version so initially the population size
is large denoting some kind of
exponential growth in the population and
more for the back in time there was sort
of a bottleneck which denotes the fact
that you know maybe there was a
contraction in the population because
maybe individuals left that population
and went out somewhere else so you
sample five lineages or five individuals
at the present time and we let tnk be
the waiting time while there are K
ancestors for a sample of size n drawn
at the present so you know these are the
the lengths of these T in case for N
equals five so as you can see so you can
you can get some intuitive prop
intuitive sense of how variation is
generated by or F is affected by these
changes in population size so for
example here where the population size
is larger the coalescence rates are
going to be smaller because remember the
the coalescence rate is inversely
proportional to the population size for
any pair of individuals so you're going
to have these longer branches because
individuals are taking longer to
coalesce when you have this exponential
growth for example so this also means
that if you have because you have longer
branches and more proportion of the
total branch lengths in this tree are
being occupied by these long branches
which only subtend one descendant any
mutation that occurs during this
intervening times will only create a
variant in one individual in your sample
right so you'll see a lot of private
mutations which only occur in one
individual in your sample and not in
anyone else so so you know this really a
the the kind of variation you see in the
genetic data that you sample from the
population only there and when you have
these bottlenecks you have actually
faster rates of coalescence so you
actually find ancestors more quickly
like this more action going on over here
and any variation that hits these would
presumably hit multiple individuals in
your sample so for example any any
variation that hits this segment here
will affect both individuals one and two
in your sample variation over here will
it will actually affect individuals one
two and three in your sample and so on
so so these will be the more common
variants that occur in your sample and
so when you have so this is sort of how
you know a population bottlenecks can
give rise to more common variants
whereas sort of more rapid increase in
population maybe recently will give rise
to more rare variants so you can try to
based on the based on the actual kind of
variance you see in data you can
actually try to infer these population
size changes that occurred in the past
so this is something that people often
do using bigger so just sort of some
some quick mathematical properties or
expressions that you can write for
example the most recent the the latest
coalescence event which occurred on a
sample of size ends so you can write the
cumulative distribution function of this
because it's simply given by a time
varying exponential distribution for
every pair of lineages there is this one
over ETA x rate of coalescence so you
can write the cumulative distribution
function and differentiate you to get
the PDF and other properties of it so
it's so but in general these these
waiting times in this collison process
are not independent random variables
because your population size changes
over time whereas if you work to the
constant size Qualis and they would
actually be independent random variables
and so it's harder to get expressions
for you know the intermediate waiting
times like the earlier waiting times in
this process but you know conditioning
on the total amount either you've
already waited in the process it's quite
easy to get the get the get the waiting
time for the next amount so you can
write these expressions fairly easily
okay so so far we only talked about the
only structure I had introduced was a
varying population size but now you
might imagine
right so so intuitively you got a sense
that based on this populations I change
this the the trees so these trees are
more likely which have these skinny
branches here just because you have a
very large population size here so the
trees which are actually very short are
quite unlikely so this is affecting the
kind so and this affects that where what
proportion of mutations leave signal in
only one individual in your sample as
opposed to large number of individuals
in your sample so there is a map from
the population size to the frequency of
variance so for a variant that only
occurs in one individual in a sample
there is some probability similarly for
each of the other accounts so there is
this map so you might want to invert
this map given the variance you might
want to find out what's what's the most
likely population size change in this
model that generated this data yeah yeah
people try to do this yeah they would
like to so the more data you have
probably the more you would expect a
more signal also here the way I
presented it was just for one you're
looking at one position in the genome so
one locus but if you have you know whole
genome sequences which you do now from
thousands of individuals you actually
get signal from so each you can think of
each genomic position the the ancestry
the genealogical ancestry of these
10,000 individuals in your sample will
will have some genealogy because tree
which might be different from the
neighboring position just because
recombination breaks up correlations so
you actually have a lot more signal just
because you have genomic data and you
yeah presumably you you can you can
infer what happens back in the past
we're dangerously close to a real data
here so maybe I you know you can you can
you can actually infer the coalescence
rate yeah yeah well that is anything to
do with populations so you yeah so in
these models you have to scale what we
work on is this this this qual essence
rate so we've we've taken a sequence of
pre limiting models and we've taken the
continuum limit but you can get back one
of the pre limiting models that you're
interested in by measuring
lately the mutation rate the per
generation physical mutation rate
through biological experiments so this
gives you back the rescaling that got
you into this continuum limit but you
can use so you use this continuum limit
model to do the estimation of these
rates then you rescale things back using
using something that's outside these
models right so the other thing that
we've assumed random meeting so there's
a question of what that really means for
a census population size so so the next
models I'll talk about gives a little
more structure to the population where
you might have separate groups so to
move forward you have you know you could
imagine now that you discretize the
space where the population lives into
some kind of lattice two-dimensional
lattice where individuals migrate
between the spaces they live in or the
population subpopulations they inhabit
at some rate so you know you have we
call these subpopulations as teams and
you know in deem alpha you could imagine
there's a population of size n alpha and
occasionally these teams will exchange
migrants because people move around and
you know if you say the per generation
probability that an offspring in in a
particular team alpha has a parent in
some deem beta going back in time if
it's given by this probability then you
can now sort of take the same kind of
scaling limits that I described that
that we developed earlier for the the
case without any structure so what would
you do you take the you know each of
these deem sizes to infinity you take
some rescaling quantity this curly n
which would be parameter ice time and
now the sample that you draw at the
present will have some number of
individuals from each of these beams so
it will be a tuple indexed by alpha and
now though the coalescence rates for any
since the coalescence rate for any pair
since individuals can only call s if
they occur in the same deal because you
know individuals have to move around
between teams the coalescence rate for
this team alpha for any pair of
individuals in that is now inversely
proportional to the
relative population size in that beam
again this makes intuitive spend smaller
teams have smaller populations so
there's faster coalescence --is
individuals in your sample fine
ancestors more quickly but the most
important sort of modification is that
there is also migration of lineages now
that occurs between teams because these
individuals are moving around and so now
the scale parameter that represents the
migration is going to be the migration
rate where you know it's related to the
you know the per generation the
discrete-time migration rate by you know
the scaling parameter the rescaling of
time that you used and so really in
these rescaling is you would say that
the you know the pearl you you're taking
the same to infinite this collie n to
infinity while this quantity is going to
zero so that this this migration rate is
approaching some constant and this is
the scale migration rate that you're
using so so you know to give concrete
example of what this Markov chain looks
like when you have say two deems we
label them alpha and beta so now the
state of the Markov chain the
genealogical process time three you have
you have is given by this tuple indexed
by alpha and beta so n alpha T is the
number of individuals in there are
ancestors of your sample in that are now
indium alpha and the number of n beta is
the number of ancestors of your sample
that are living in team Beatle right now
so now if you look at a state n which is
an alpha and beta and you look at the
transitions out of it in this Markov
chain this continuous time Markov chain
so now because of coalescence with with
Indy mouths alpha you lose one lineage
and email from so two individuals
coalesce and find a common ancestor and
that happens at this rate which is an
alpha choose two which was in which is
the same rate that you have in the
standard coalescence but now it's
augmented by the fact that you have to
take into account their relative
population size this is a smaller deal
so this would have maybe a faster
coalescence rate similarly you can do
this for the beta but but sort of the
new event is the migration event so you
have a migration back in time where an
individual from D Malcolm moves to D in
beta so you lose one individual and in
half D map and you gain one in
individual beta in Indian beta in this
ancestral process and this happens with
rate proportional to this this this this
migration parameter
and since there are n alpha individuals
the this is what gets multiplied for the
total rate of these migrations out and
similarly you can do you can do the same
thing for migration from being beta to D
alpha so you know how can this be
visualized so you imagine that in a one
beam Qualis and you just have a tree
relating the individuals but now you
have two demes
so you have the sample that you draw at
prison there are five individuals drawn
from D 1 or D mouth and five individuals
from being beta and you can look at
answers to retrieve relating the so you
can look at this answers through so I
you have to draw this line now so there
there's actually more structure than
simply your tree relating these
individuals so here going back in time
this individual actually found an
ancestor in the previous beam so it
actually migrated over here again there
was a migration that happened and so you
can represent sort of by these pictures
you would have more complicated pictures
of course in in depending on how many
teams you have and the fact that you
can't embed them in a plane so easily so
you won't get as nice pictures so now in
practice what people do to mention
population structure is they like to
summarize things by a single number
which gives them a sense of how
structured the population is a common
measure is called FST and to describe it
we need we need some notation so if you
let P sub squared W of theta be the
probability that two individuals sampled
from the same team are identical by
descent so identical by descent means
that these two individuals had a common
ancestor and there was no intervening
mutation that occurred between these two
individuals and this and this was a
common ancestor of these two individuals
so so you can write this quantity for
the in for a pair of individual sample
from the same team you can also write
this the quantity for the pair of
individual sample from different themes
so that would be P subscript B of theta
and you know by the mutation process we
know that PW of theta is is an
expectation of this quantity each of the
minus theta TW where this is the
probability that there was no mu
that occurred where TWU is the time to
coalescence so this is a random quantity
now for these two individual sample from
the same beam and similarly for PB or
theta you can write the same thing and
now the way you summarize the structure
in the population is by this quantity
FST which measures the difference
between the prompt the probability of
identity by descent within the lineage
sorry within the same team minus the
average probability of identity by
descent where this average means that
now you're sampling two individuals at
random but this is across all deems so
you're taking into account the deme
sizes when you're doing the sampling and
you normalize it by this quantity the
normalization would ensure that this FST
is going to be between zero and one zero
means that there's actually no
substructure in the in the population
that is this is perfectly randomly
mating so this is like one deep
essentially and all the individual this
is just as in the regular coalescent
without any sub structure and FST 1
means that these populations are
completely isolated they don't exchange
migrates between each other so so this
number I sort of is you know gives you a
convenient way of summarizing how much
structure there is in the population and
you know for small mutation rates this
is roughly given by you know 1 minus the
the relative the ratio between the
coalescence time within for to
individual sample within within a single
team with respect to the average
coalescence time for any pair of
individual sample across these teams so
you know very studies try to estimate
this these this quantity FST from using
existing genetic data and they would
like to sort of get a sense of how
related individuals are across different
parts of the world so you know for
humans some of these estimate that the
FST is on the order of 0.1 or 10% and
this sort of says that you know there's
fairly little structure is that is there
people across different themes or
different parts of the world are fairly
similar the genetic variation across
them is fairly similar you can also sort
of go into some details for very simple
examples in general sort of working with
these models with very complicated
migration structures
is a little tricky you have to do Monte
Carlo integration or you have to do
simulations important sampling other
things but for simple very simple
examples you can actually write out
recurrences for these these quantities
that I described earlier
so suppose we you know the the most time
example would be you had the symmetric
island model where there are these
islands where you can move between
between any two deems and sort of your
migrations are with equal probability
between any pair of Nimes
so so if you let this migration rate be
sort of M over G minus one where you
have G demes
and you have this mutation rate then
then by conditioning on what happens
what is the most recent event for a
sample of size two whether it happened
to be a migration or whether it happened
to be a coalescence you can write out or
it happened to be a mutation you can
write out the probabilities of IBD or
the probability that two individuals
have a common ancestor there's no
intervening mutation between the common
ancestor these individuals and you can
solve these recurrences to get explicit
values for these these probabilities and
then you can compute the this FST and
other quantities for these simple
examples okay so you can also have sort
of more complicated structure or more
complicated demographic models where you
incorporate migration and changing
population sizes at the same time so
really now when you have data you
actually look at very complicated models
where you have many different
populations so sort of these big trunks
denote separate populations which so
there was one randomly mating population
that maybe split up into two at this
time then maybe this population
underwent a bottleneck and this this
population underwent further splits so
you could imagine maybe this was the
African population it and there was a
there was a split and this was maybe the
eurasian population and then there was a
further split so that this might be the
european and this might be the asian
population and maybe there's more recent
migration that happens between these
populations so you you could infer all
these parameters based on the genetic
data that you sample from these
different populations at the current
time okay now i will switch to sort of
another evolution course we
combination which is very critical when
you want to modern sequence data so what
does recombination do it generates new
genetic variation in sexual organisms so
you know as you all know humans are
diploid organisms we have two copies of
every chromosome so these are called
homologous copies or homologous
chromosomes one from the mother and one
from the father now in the first phase
of meiosis this or this the synthesis
phase of meiosis what happens is each
chromosome gets duplicated it has twice
it and these duplicates are called
chromatids and these sister chromatids
are tied together at the centromere so
initially this chromosome had an Al
yield at this position and a B allele at
this position and when I duplicated it
had it formed this other sister
chromatid and they they they were joined
together as a centromere and so this
might be the maternal copy and this is
the paternal copy or the other
homologous copy of that chromosome now
in the in one of the later phases the
prophase one stage of meiosis what
happens is these two homologous copies
come together in physical contact and
they exchange genetic material so this
sister chromatid on this copy exchange
direct material with this sister
chromatid on this copy and basically
this this creates a new so so now if you
look at this new chromatid it actually
has a different variant from either of
the paternal or maternal copies so this
creates a new haplotype or a new
daughter cell copy so at the end of
meiosis basically you you started with
this diploid cell and you got four
haploid cells so these are the these are
the copies in the four cells so you have
these endo so this this particular
haplotype or variant was present in your
your metronome copy this particular one
was present in your paternal copy but
these mosaics were not present in either
of the copies so recombination has
managed to generate a new haplotypic
variant from existing variation so so so
why is it important so as we just saw I
mean this kind of mixing this
coupling together creates new variation
this also breaks down the correlation
that is in the genealogies of the two
different positions so now if you look
at if this member was present in a
sample this this particular allele was
or this particular position was
inherited from maybe the maternal copy
and this particular position was
inherited from the paternal copy so the
genealogies for these two positions is
different and this this fact has
implications for many problems that many
data analytic problems in population
genetics so one of the things you want
to do is face genotype data in tools
into haplotype data so what happens is
when your sequence you want you get sort
of the you get the total variation and
both the maternal and paternal copies
and you'd like to separate this out
between the two so you'd like to know
which variants occur together on the
maternal copy and which variants occur
on the paternal copy but maybe a
sequencing only gives you actually a
mosaic of the two you'd also like to use
this kind of the recombination maps to
impute or figure out what are the
missing variations that at different
positions you maybe you have adjacent
you have information about the adjacent
nucleotides but you don't have
information about this nucleotide may be
due to sequencing error or other
problems and if you if you have some
reference panel which tells you sort of
you know if you have a variant a at this
position you're more likely to have a
variant be at this position at this
adjacent position because you have this
statistics from reference data and these
these two individuals are close together
most likely in your in in your in the
position you're looking at where you
have missing data just by looking an
adjacent site and looking at how the
variation is distributed for in your
panel you can probably guess and give
some posterior estimates of what the
allele would be that's missing and
similarly for disease read mapping
disease association mapping where you
might not have full genome sequence data
maybe you only have your your
polymorphism data at different positions
that there are subsets of all the
variants that occur but because there is
correlation between between nucleotides
that are close by together if you can
if you can actually use the truth so
maybe the true genetic marker that's
correlated with the disease has not been
sampled in your study but something
close to it has been sampled so just
because of this fact that there that
recombination breaks up things that are
distance away there the ancestry of
these two markers that are close by a
shed and this will give you some idea
about this this can still help you find
the genomic rough genomic regions where
the genotype is correlated with the
phenotype and similarly you can you know
using this fact you can also infer the
ancestry of
sort of admixed individuals at different
positions of their genome you can also
use this for detecting signatures of
natural selection where maybe some some
of you that's selected for is on some is
has some other alleles close by to it
and just because those alleles are close
to it and this allele is selected and it
increases in frequency and the fact that
the other allele is close by this will
actually also increase in frequency even
though this allele might not confer any
selective advantage so it's sort of
hitchhikes along it free loads along
with this with this allele that's
beneficial and this is again due to the
fact that that positions that are close
by are correlated to each other so you
would like to sort of introduce
recombination so we can start with the
right Fisher model with recombination so
you start again with the population size
and individuals so let's start with two
positions now a to low side where
there's some recombination rate or
distance between them so with
probability R which is sort of going to
indicate the probability of a
recombination event this these two lows
I will pick parents from the previous
generation independently and uniformly
at random so for example there was a
recombination that occurred here between
these two loci it just so happened that
these two picked the same parent from
the previous generation but if you
looked at this particular individual the
left locus picked up at the left picked
a parent which is different from the
parent picked by the right locus whereas
the other ones
there was no recombination so you know
with probably one - rlu you just pick a
parent for both low-side uniformly at
random so again you can take the
continuum limit for these things and you
can get a sort of
continuing a continuous-time process ad
that creates genealogies at both
positions but not just creating
genealogies at both positions it also
gives you correlation between the
genealogies of the two positions so you
need a more complex truck a more complex
structure than simply a tree at either
position but he needs some kind of
structure that represents the joint
trees at these two positions so so what
are some desiderata or things we'd like
from such a process so we want to model
the the correlations between at both
low-side marginally though we like the
process at each locus to be the same
process that we had developed earlier
right this for consistency we we don't
want to have something completely new we
want something that embeds the earlier
one locus processes so you know you can
take sort of the extreme cases if there
was no recombination between these two
positions the genealogies at both
positions should be identical because
these two positions are inherited
together as a unit because there's no
recombination on the other hand though
if there was free recombination like
these individuals these two positions
are completely unrelated or completely
uncorrelated then you expect the
genealogies to be independent and in
general the genealogies of these two
positions will have some non-trivial
correlation between them because the
recombination rate is something finite
between zero and infinity for these
between these two positions that are
located on the same chromosome so the
structure that we will that we will
develop is this answers through
recombination graph so we start with the
sample of size four individuals
specified at two positions now the kind
of events that can happen in this in
this in this graph are in the structure
is there could be a coalescence event as
usual or a recombination event so a
coalescence event is where you know
these two individuals for example find a
common ancestor at both positions but
this individual going back in time
experience a recombination where the
left so this ancestor here contributed
the left fragment to or the left locust
locust a to this individual at the
present in the sample
but as it didn't contribute the the
second the the B locus to the individual
in the sample so we actually don't we
we don't show it there because the
ancestry of this locus is not that it's
not important because it doesn't
contribute any genetic multi-material to
to the sample at present and you know
this this ancestor here contributed the
second the B locus to the sample at
present and it didn't contribute the the
a locus now going back in time there was
a coalescence event between these two
individuals so there was there was an
there was an ancestor here that
contributed the left and right locus to
this individual contributed the left
locus here contributed the right locus
to this this individual here but it this
didn't really matter because it didn't
contribute anything to the sample at
present so you have this complicated
graph structure that represents both
koala senses and recombinations
now if you look just at what's happening
at the left locus for every individual
in your sample at present then you get a
marginal so marginalizing what's
happening at the left locus you get a
tree just on the left or the a locus and
this is how the answers free looks like
so we just care about what's happening
at the left locus so we don't actually
trace back what's happening at the right
locus and you see that the most recent
common ancestor of the samples at the
left locus is actually this individual
here at this locus whereas if you look
at what's happening on the P locus you
have another tree actually and the most
recent common ancestor of the sample
that this locus B is actually much
higher up in the tree so as you can see
the the the total the time spent in this
process to the most recent common
ancestor at the left locus is different
from what it is at the right locus in
this particular example you know again
generally these these quantities are
different so how do we actually
construct this this graph representation
and sort of how do we see that this
graph representation generates the one
locust trees consistently at when you
marginalize the tree on the Left locus
or on the right locus okay so like we
said the per generation per individual
probability of recombination between the
two lows is R and there is a we can
introduce the scaled version of the
recombination rate just like we had
scale versions of the mutation rate the
scaled versions of the migration rate we
have a scale version of the
recombination rate where you take R to 0
n to infinity and
while this case this approach is a
constant and now the configuration that
you give for your sample is now
specified by actually four four numbers
so at a time T the the the ancestral
process Markov chain has state given by
this tuple the first component of this
tuple a of T is the number of ancestors
at this time that contribute genetic
material to the original sample that is
sampled at time 0 at the left locus at
locus a similarly B of T is the number
of ancestors that come to be genetic
material to the right locus in your
sample C of T will be those ancestors
that contribute generating material to
the to the original sample at time 0 at
both the left and the right locus and D
of T will be the number of ancestors at
time T that don't contribute genetic
material at either of the low-side to
your sample so now once you once you
write this you can you know once you
create the state space you can write
this continuous time Markov chain again
by going from this this discrete time
right Fisher model that I described
earlier taking the continuum limit in
the same way and you can write these
rates out so for example so I used
starch to denote the fact that this at
this locus we don't have ancestral
material being contributed to the sample
at present so here for example if you
have two individuals that are trying to
coalesce which have which are
contributing ancestry material at both
Llosa the transition rates from this
tuple so now you have a decrease in the
C component and this the transitions
happen at rate c choose two similarly
you can write the transition rates that
are happening for coalescence events for
all other for all of these pairs of cool
essences that occur there are sort of 10
possibilities and you can write down all
these things you can also write what's
happening for the recombination events
so here there is a recombination event
where this this individual who is
contributing genetic material at both
loss I a and B there is a recombination
backwards in time so you have this left
fragment and you know the the right
fragment of this ancestor is not
contributing any genetic material to
this individual and similarly you have
this you have the other ancestor which
is only contributing the right fragment
and not the length left fragment that's
why again your
it's your topple is changing so you have
an increase in the number of ancestors
that are only contributing the left
fragment the ancestor that's
contributing the right penguin increases
by one the total number of ancestors
surviving that contribute both fragments
decrease by one because that's what
happened here
and the other component doesn't change
and similarly you can write recon with
the the recombination rates for the
other configurations also and there are
four such events so you can summarize
all these transitions I'm just getting
to that actually so so if you summarize
the transitions out of this couple the
state this this four top loop you can
write down these rates and now the
absorbing states of this Markov chain
this ancestral process are those tuples
where you know you've found a common
ancestor that's contributing genetic
material at both low side to your sample
so there's only one such an system and
that ancestor is remaining and you don't
care about those the number of
individuals that are not contributing
any genetic material at any low side to
your sample so these are the absorbing
states of your Markov chain and you know
as usual you can impose mutations on
this geological process once you have
the this this this this generator
constructor just this graph relating the
sample and so you have these marginal
trees you can just impose the mutations
on each of these marginal trees as usual
in the standard koalas in weight now as
Daniel mentioned this fourth component
that we kept track of the number of the
number of ancestors that do not
contribute genetic material either low
sy those don't really matter because
those since they are not going to be in
any genetic material any mutation that
occurs that those individuals don't
affect the sample at present so they do
not affect the probability distribution
of data you observe at present so we
actually don't need to keep track of
them in the Markov chain
so we now the ready state representation
in in your radius state space Markov
chain has just three components so we
just dropped the fourth component and
you can write down the transition rates
again just ignoring any transitions that
sort of alter D and now there's only one
absorbing state it's that state where
you found a common ancestor that's that
that is contributing genetic material at
both positions of your at both low side
so so you know looking at this looking
at the actual states in these in this in
this example genealogy that we sampled
for these four individuals at two loci
so here originally my sample had four
individuals and you know this this
corresponds to the C component being
four because these four individuals were
the ancestors trivially of the sample at
each of those two positions each of
those two lows I going back in time the
first event was a coalescence event so
there is one less ancestor that
contributes genetic material at both
lows I going further back in time the
next event is a recombination event so
there is now one ancestral lineage that
contributes in generating material only
at the left locus one that contributes
only at the right locus and the total
number of ancestors that contribute
generating material both loss I has
dropped by one so it's two and so on you
can go back in this process and
eventually you find a ancestor this the
most recent common ancestor at both low
side so it has come to be a generating
material both low side and this is the
first such ancestor that has done so
even though the first ancestor that has
contributed genetic material at only the
left locus is actually this individual
so these marginal ancestors most recent
common ancestors are different and then
the grand most recent common ancestor at
both positions is different okay how do
we see that this process is consistent
with what we saw earlier at just one
genomic position so you can actually
show that the the correlation process at
just locus a is embedded the Markov
chain for this coalition processes
embedded in the disjoint
the squalus in process with
recombination at both loss i a and B so
you know for the states for the state
ABC for this in this coalition process
with recombination there were a plus C
ancestors that contribute genetic
material locus a right because C
contributes ready material at both locus
a and B so it just summing these two up
and now if you group these States
together into the sort of one super
state so if you let s sub M be the set
of states in this Markov chain within
the recombination process which have M
sort of ancestors that contribute that
that contra genetic material to your
sample where now M is the sum of a plus
C so there actually many such
states that that form part of the super
state and then you just look at
transitions from the state ABC to those
where this quantity a plus C changes now
this is going to represent changes that
move out of the super state that you're
looking at right and now if you look at
the total rate of transitions out of the
super state it's so so those can those
the the some of those transitions is
simply given by M choose to where m was
the number of individuals that
contributed material at the left
position so this M choose two is the
same rate that you see in the
coalescence process in the one locus
coalition process right on em because
now the state really you're looking at
is with M individuals at the left locus
okay so this is how we see that you know
at the left locus is consistent so now
you can show at the right locus it's
also consistent so what are some
challenges associated with modeling
recombination so you know this was
simply for two low side but you can
extend this process and electricity for
multiple those I so if you have in
general Kalos I with some recombination
distance between each pair each pair of
adjacent lows I the the state space of
your Markov chain this reduced state
space Markov chain will now have two to
the K minus 1 components in your topple
right because this is going to represent
all the combinations of number of
ancestors that contribute genetic
material at this combination of our
subsets of low side that you're
interested in for your for your sample
at present and sort of the state space
itself of the Markov chain if you sample
n individuals at the present is going to
grow as n to the 2k roughly right so
this is this is an enormous state space
if K is large and in fact for even for
large K and you know realistic
recombination rates or large or say
larger recombination rates that you see
in Drosophila and some other species
this this will create many sort of these
these fragments that our ancestor only
at some subset of the low side but not
all the positions so you're going to
have the the coalition process that you
have to model you have to go back in
time to simulate you would have to go
further back in time to simulate just
because the recombination rate is large
and you're tracking many low sighs so
simulating data under this process is
very challenging and now you can ask
actually the question of actually
computing the probability of
some observed data so when you have
observed data you need to integrate over
the uncertainty in the general in the
genealogies at every of these positions
this drawing structure in the mutations
that could have happened that produced
the data at prison so that becomes
really challenging and in practice even
if you just look at two locus data that
is used modeling two positions at a time
and you just have maybe two alleles that
eat put it at each position and even a
small sample size of a few hundred appro
types computing the probability exactly
of the data under this generative model
is is actually very difficult and sort
of many approximation or heuristics have
to be used to to tackle this problem so
far I haven't talked about natural
selection at all but you can sort of
very easily imagine writing a write
Fisher model for natural selection where
the number of offsprings produced by
each individual now depends on the type
of the individual because that the type
determines its fitness and you can also
construct a coalition time model which
is this sort of backwards in time model
for a sample but that geological
structure that you get from it is far
more complicated than any of the things
we've seen so far it's and you get
something called the answers from
selection graph from it and people don't
really use this for algorithmic
inference from data so a better way to
handle sort of selection is through
forward in time orders that is taking
the forwarding time continuum limits of
these right Fisher models and Steve is
going to talk about that in the next
lecture and yeah this is all I had
planned to talk about with extensions to
the standard one locus coalescing